-Thank you for being here
on such a busy week.
I know they're all sort of bus
at this point.
But, you know, we were talking
backstage, all of us have to b
careful about our hygiene
right now.
You're obviously a politicia
who enjoys interacting wit
your constituents.
There's a lot of handshakes,
a lot of hugging.
Is it overwhelming for you
-It can be overwhelming.
I'm trying to make sure that
I'm practicing great hygiene
Everyone, learn how to
wash your hands.
-Yeah.
-I retweeted
a handwashing tutorial.
And I was shocked by
how many people were like,
"Oh, wait, what?
We were supposed to be doing
this 20 seconds?"
[ Laughter ]
-I will say
when I heard 20 seconds,
I thought I'm just going to do
normal and see where I get to.
And it was -- I definitely
didn't break double digits
I know that.
[ Laughter ]
You know, you guys -- the Hous
voted to approve $8 billio
in coronavirus aid,
which is great.
Matt Gaetz -- we mentioned him
in the monologue --
he's one of your colleagues.
He's a Republican,
and he wore a gas mask.
-Yes, he did.
With matching shoes.
-With the matching shoes.
Yeah, I feel like nobody -
Nobody who's ever worn that mask
has worn those shoes.
[ Laughter ]
-No. No.
-That's a real first.
-I will say,
I have days in Congress
where I feel like wearing a mask
like that.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Just not for, like, corona
or anything, just for the --
-No, no, just the debates.
-Yeah.
-The toxicity.
Is it helpful when somebod
goes to an important vote
like that wearing a gas mask
-No, of course it's not helpful.
[ Laughter ]
We're not here to incite panic
-Yeah.
I will say,
he doesn't look panicked.
He's just fully texting.
-Yeah, he doesn't.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I do want to ask
Representative Gaetz
how often he washes his hands.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That would be a good questio
because then you don't nee
the gas mask
if you just do that basic stuff.
One of the things that,
you know, a lot of people
are discussing is who the
President has chosen to pu
in charge of this task force
He chose Vice President Pence.
Is it safe to assume
that you do not think
that's the best of his options
-No, no.
-Yeah.
-I think that we should have a
person who believes in science
-Sure. That sounds good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ideally, what we have is
a person who believes in
universal healthcare
and paid sick leave
and an agenda that actually...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...can help prevent
the transmission of disease.
-Well, it's interesting
you mention paid sick leav
because one of the things
that's been pointed out
by a lot of people is especially
in the food-service industry
these are people with jobs
that are very important to them.
You know, they're just makin
ends meet as it is.
And, you know, they are the ones
who are most likely to pass on
whatever illness they have
to other people.
And yet they don't have that
opportunity.
-Exactly, and the other issue,
too, to compound on that,
especially in food service
you know, a lot of people know
that I used to work
in a restaurant.
And that just
a couple weeks ago,
Stephen Miller and the Trump
administration rolled out
a public-charge rule
against undocumented people,
many of whom we know work
in the food-service industry
And basically
what it says is that
if you are seeking medical care,
that could be used against you
in deportation proceedings
And so the people who feed u
are now scared
to seek medical care.
This is not a situation
that befits us as a country.
And it's one that, frankly
I think shows that we are
as strong as
the most vulnerable --
who we allow to be vulnerabl
and most vulnerable
in our society.
-You mentioned
universal healthcare.
You mentioned paid sick leave.
I think these are probably som
of the reasons
that you have chosen to endors
Senator Bernie Sanders.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-While I have you, though,
I want to get your take
on the fact that
Elizabeth Warren
suspended her campaign today
-Absolutely.
Well, first and foremost,
I think that we should all
take a moment to acknowledge
the historic candidacy
that Elizabeth Warren
represented.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She's a champion.
And I think that she ran
an absolutely stunning,
incredible race.
I support and I'm looking
forward to continuing this fight
for Bernie as well.
Tomorrow -- Or rather next wee
we have contests
in Michigan
and many other states.
And we need right now,
I think what we are seeing
in the primary contest is that
this is a generational battl
and that we need young peopl
to turn out to vote.
It is young people that will
champion student-loan debt
Medicare for all,
paid sick leave, a living wage
And as well as our elders that
have been in this fight
for generations as well,
fighting for progressive futur
for the United States
of America,
which, by the way,
is a winning future
for the United States of
America.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You mentioned the youth vote,
and, obviously, you know,
when you look at
the demographics of how people
are voting, young people are
flocking to Bernie Sanders
And yet it does seem like what
happened on Super Tuesday,
maybe how we didn't meet
his expectations,
were that young people wer
voting less than they need t
for Bernie's path.
Why do you think young peopl
are not coming out
in the way that you would hope
-I think we're seeing
kind of a wax and wane.
In Iowa, we saw about,
I believe,
a 30% increase in youth turnout.
And as we saw in Iowa,
Bernie Sanders came in either,
depending on who you're asking
he came in first
or quite nearly first.
Similar phenomena
in New Hampshire
with very high turnout.
I think with Super Tuesday wit
so many states voting at once,
we have to reiterate
that message
because it is going to be no
and in November, I believe
turnout of young people that
will have a huge determination
in our future as a country
And this is
an enormous responsibility
And we got to really,
really turn up or else --
you know, we get what --
you get what you fight for
And you get what you vote for.
And I think it's so incredibly
important that we fight
for a future
that will work for us,
that we fight for
a Green New Deal,
action on climate,
that we fight for ending our
system of mass incarceration